[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
boiling mama's head down in the pot on
the stove in the kitchen
a gruesome scene as a tennessee man is
trying for allegedly stabbing and
dismembering
his parents his own notebook holds key
evidence
also a texas sheriff is under arrest
charged with tampering with evidence in
the death of a man
in custody who said he couldn't breathe
and
a judge orders grand jury records open
to the public in the death of brianna
taylor
law and crime daily covers court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome to long crime daily
everybody i'm erin keller along with
brian buckmeyer and terry
austin prosecutors are presenting
evidence for the second day in the trial
of joel guy jr a tennessee man accused
of stabbing his parents to death
even cooking some of their body parts on
the stove
over thanksgiving weekend the testimony
centered largely
around forensics law on crime daily's
brian buckmeyer explains brian
say joel jr planned for weeks to kill
his parents and get rid of their bodies
some of the details of how they say he
did it are especially disturbing
jurors saw crime scene photos including
this pot lisa guy's head was discovered
inside
blood splatter covered the walls and
bloody shoe prints trailed
led through the home one investor called
it a lot of movement
professor forensic joseph scott morgan
reviewed the victim's autopsy
and tells law and crime he was surprised
at the death of the defendant's alleged
preparations
he's utilizing a method essentially
that we would use in forensics where you
would take the head
off put it into a pot and you don't need
an agent or anything like
you know an acid you just place the body
in water
and put or put the head in water and
turn it at a very slow
or very low temperature and kind of
slowly allow it to heat
uh and so that's that's a very curious
thing i i'd like to know
how he came into that knowledge what
what kind of
pushed him in that direction to use that
methodology because
there are a number of ways he's trying
to utilize here we've got
cutting of the body rendering down to
the body with acid
and now we have this gruesome scene of
him actually boiling
uh mama's head down in the pot on the
stove in the kitchen
and now to terry austin with how the
sheriff's office says they were able to
link the defendant to the killings of
his parents terry
well crime scene investigators combed
the house looking for
any clues the suspect left behind they
took swabs from knives
shoes and door handles but what might be
most damning for the defense
was what the authorities found on items
the state says
the defendant used to clean up the
murders the
first particular case i developed it
with black powder
lifted two prints and
took them in and entered them into aphis
automated fingerprint identification
system
and got a response back that was from
the clorox glove package second print
was actually
on the same card it was a double
impression
where the individual had touched it
twice
in almost the exact same place okay so
how many fingerprints in total
were you able to positively identify
joel michael guy jr
as the owner of those prints six and the
leighton print
is on the left hand side the known print
is on the right side all the green dots
represent
corresponding ridge endings and
bifurcations that are consistent
on both prints as having come from the
same source
and one of the officers who testified
earlier in the case describes the
initial discovery
of the shocking evidence do you see
anything
once you get to the top of the stairs
yes sir when i get to the top of the
steps i believe
i believed it to be a human hand or a
hand
lying at the very end of the hallway
okay
and did you go a different way or have
caused to go a different way than
detective mccord did initially when
you're clearing the residence yes sir
detective
ford broke off immediately to the right
and kind of behind where i was and i
continued
down the hallway okay and where you
think you see hands you eventually make
it
to that room sir yes sir and do you
clear that room
yes sir partially yes sir and if you
would
describe what you see in that room i see
a human hand it was lying in an upright
position
with another human hand that was closed
fist
behind it and after you make those
observations
what do you collectively do as the
officers who are clearing the residence
detective mcchord had seen something in
one of the other rooms
and requested that we back out at that
point
and at that point we worked our way back
out of the residence
and i went if you were facing their
residence i went to the outside
far back right of the residence and held
a perimeter
until we could get additional officers
on scene
and still ahead on law and crime daily
we'll show you pages from the notebook
prosecutors say defendant jill guy jr
used
to plan the killings and later on
updates in the police shooting death
of brianna taylor why the public is
about to learn a lot more about what
happened behind the closed doors of the
grand jury proceeding
law on crime daily we'll be right back
[Music]
we're back now to the trial of jewel guy
jr where the state said during opening
statements that they have
evidence from the defendant's own hand
that these gruesome killings were
planned
well good morning to our jury thank you
once again for being here today
prosecutors say defendant joel guy jr
kept a notebook of plans for his
murderous plot
from killing to clean up to cover up
killing
get knives quiet multiple get
sledgehammer
crush bones get carving knives to make
small pieces
bring blender why make this a stabbing
he worries that he will be seen buying
bullets so the plan became
kill her with knife take dog with you
place her in shower
turn on hot water and point at her to
get rid of forensics
remove her clothes and take them with me
for disposal
get rid of bodies inside house there and
my dna
already there flush chunks down toilet
not garbage disposal he needs to be
blended
not intruder get plastic sheeting for
disposal purposes
elsewhere he writes bring blender and
food grinder grind meat
and get bleach he wrote the defendant
seems to have been trying to make it
look like his father killed his mother
and ran off cut off his arm and plant
his flesh
under her fingernails place her hand
with his dna
so that his dna is not washed away by
shower
ultraviolet light shows fingerprints
check mail before leaving
to get rid of blood use peroxide for
hemoglobin
and bleach for dna but might the police
catch him
body gives time of death the defendant
worried with an arrow to alibi
don't have to get rid of body if there
is no forensic evidence on the body
destruction of bodies one note says and
it lists
the composition of the body the bleach
he thought
would denature proteins get plastic bin
for denaturation process
does not matter where they're killed
just get rid of bloody spots to prevent
evidence of time of death
place him in plastic bin and use it to
get him
into the upstairs bathroom what about
the getaway
leave through front door and wipe down
doorknobs timer for
flammable set for friday at 10 a.m
sunlight masks fire but not smoke
everyone at work so they can't report it
the defendant had a motive prosecutor
say
relatives testified the victims were
planning to retire and live on a pension
and wouldn't have enough money to pay
for their son's apartment
she had stated that they were going to
retire
and it was time for joe michael to stand
on his own two feet he was an adult
and did she discuss her future plans on
whether or not she
could help support her son she said that
uh she couldn't do that no more
okay that he needed to be on his own
they said if they were gonna
wait till christmas to talk to joel
michael that they were gonna have to
have him to start paying his bills and
stuff okay they had said that
they um were retiring and that they were
moving to sick hornsville
and that joel michael was going
to find a job or need to find a job
because they were no longer their
money when they sat down and determined
even down to the amount of beer that
they drink a week and the amount of
cigarettes that they have a week
what amount of money they would need and
that amount of money was what they had
to retire
during a profit session outside the
presence of the jury the defense asked
an important question on cross
that would have played straight into the
prosecutor's hands had the jury heard it
your brother he stated that he had
already cut off
his son is that right yes okay and as
to your sister-in-law the test she told
you she was
planning to cut him off at christmas is
that right yes
the defendant's own note seemed to
corroborate that he knew he was about to
lose support from his parents
assets her life insurance possibly more
with double indemnities
with him missing dead i get the whole
thing
he's not alive to claim her half of the
insurance money all mine
five hundred thousand dollars so terry
this seems like a strong case for the
state in my opinion at least and i
realize we're just in the states portion
of the evidence but when you take these
handwritten notes to thing
into consideration here i should say
this looks like premeditation
absolutely i don't think you could get a
stronger case
unless the defendant himself went on the
stand and said i murdered and
slaughtered my parents we have
overwhelming circumstantial evidence
we have the motive the opportunity the
means and to your point
we have a handwritten note that shows
premeditation
so there is no question in my mind that
this case is
a slam dunk brian buckmaier you're used
to taking the pressure like this
public defender what's the defense i
don't think this defendant uh really has
a defense or is employing one at least
through this defense council
really they're just holding tight to the
burden of proof
but if i'm about to take this case on
i've got to somehow show that that book
has no connection with my client
whether it be a writing analyst and then
also try to shift
that motive to maybe another sibling
because if my client didn't really know
he's gonna get cut off
a lot of other siblings seem to know
that so terry remember this is a case
where the defendant has asked the judge
to
put him to death bizarrely if he's
convicted
we're almost forgetting that element of
this as well
well that's right and that shows some
culpability of guilt
because he is saying i'm guilty please
put me to death i don't want to have a
life sentence or anything less than that
so
i think if the jury had that information
obviously that would make sure that he
was convicted as well
rarely does this happen brian but we
oftentimes see a story behind a story
and in this case it seems like there
might be one we heard a little bit more
on the prophet sessions and the jury
ultimately heard
as to this financial motive yeah it's
it's
it's something that the prosecution
doesn't have to prove because you don't
have to prove motive
but it's definitely something that's
going to directly point circumstantial
evidence
to the defendant when prosecutors have
motive they love to use it
and coming up after the break a federal
appeals court forces prosecutors to eat
their own words
we'll tell you how a trial went
drastically wrong for the state of
california
plus a texas sheriff is under arrest by
his own department over his handling of
the
in-custody death of a man who said he
couldn't breathe
learn how the sheriff is fighting back
after the break
a new hampshire couple is under arrest
after a wife told authorities her
husband
shot and killed her lover and then
ordered her to chop off the dead man's
head and bury it separately
from the body brittany barron is charged
with falsifying evidence armando baron
charged with capital murder for
allegedly killing the lover
with assault for allegedly beating his
wife during the ordeal on top of that
the body of the victim 25 year old
jonathan amaral was left alone
for four days authorities say a texas
sheriff and a government attorney are
both under arrest for allegedly
tampering with physical evidence in the
in-custody death of a man last year
body camera footage shows police tasing
javier ambler four times
as he told officers he couldn't breathe
and couldn't comply with commands
to put his hands behind his back
ambler's death
occurred while photographers from the
former a e series live pd were with the
officers
a e says live pd never aired its own
footage and that the authorities
never asked the show to hand it over an
ethics disclosure on our behalf the
founder of the law and crime network dan
abrams
was the host of live pd and a e owns a
portion of the law and crime network
the sheriff's attorney says the arrest
is a political stunt leading up to an
election
and that the evidence he's accused of
destroying was of no significance to the
factual determination that the officers
did nothing wrong
a california murder convict will receive
a new trial because the prosecutor who
tried him botched the law
the ninth circuit court of appeals ruled
that a closing argument presented by a
state prosecutor
violated the defendant's constitutional
right to due process
when the prosecutor said the following
this idea
of this presumption of innocence is over
mr ford the defendant had a fair trial
we were here for three weeks where he
gets to cross-examine witnesses also an
opportunity to present evidence
information through his lawyer
he had a fair trial this system is not
perfect but he heard a fair opportunity
and a fair trial he's not presumed
innocent
anymore brian the beginning of the
prosecutor's statement and the end of it
especially
were the words the court had a serious
problem with here
because it's incorrect the presumption
of innocence is maintained until the
jury decides that the evidence has been
proven
beyond a reasonable doubt so if you're
saying that at summation and especially
if this is a
jurisdiction where the prosecutor goes
first and the defense goes afterwards
this is a mistrial this isn't this isn't
just well the judge is going to give a
curative
explanation that bell has been wrung a
jury has already heard that
and when you think about how this case
ended up so divided it's more than a
harmless error the jury was up and down
they were hung for a while they came
back with a
with an oddly split murder a verdict in
this case terry
so how could the prosecutor have avoided
the issue thank goodness there was an
objection there but how could the
prosecutor have handled the issue
should the prosecutor have just simply
not gone anywhere near the presumption
of innocence here
well you know what you have to do in
your summation aaron is
you can repeat the facts that went into
evidence and you can talk
about the law that you know the jury
will be instructed upon
what the judge said what you cannot do
is what was done
here which is to mischaracterize the law
as brian said
the defendant is innocent until proven
guilty and by mischaracterizing it
and saying that you know he no longer
has that presumption
he stepped over the bounds now brian i
know you would also have made a timely
objection in a case like this
and the sad thing is it wasn't granted
at the trial level
timely objection table flipped over yeah
sure tomato tomato aaron
but you've got to preserve the record
and thankfully that's what the defense
attorney did here
to allow the court of appeals to come to
this right decision there certainly was
a right way for prosecutors to say we
believe
we have met our burden that is a totally
different thing
than what was said here we'll watch the
case to see if it gets appealed up the
chain any further the next stop would be
the supreme court
let's check in with now with chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
with a look at what he's working on this
week
thanks aaron coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
former playboy playmate karen mcdougall
was paid 150 000
not to talk about an affair the white
house says never happened
but now she's talking with us saying
she's asked for god's forgiveness for
her sins
for having an affair with a married man
do you imagine donald trump has in any
way repented
to be honest i doubt it plus the
president's taxes
we'll talk with pulitzer prize-winning
journalist david k johnson
he's been tracking mr trump's finances
for years that's coming up this week i'm
brian ross investigates aaron on the law
and crime trial network
and when we come back here on law and
crime daily an officer enters his plea
after
a grand jury hands up an indictment
related to the police shooting of
rihanna taylor
that is when law on crime daily returns
right after this
the only louisville kentucky officer
indicted in the briana taylor case has
pleaded not guilty to account of wanton
endangerment
now fire detective brett hankinson was
indicted on three charges for shooting
into an occupied apartment next to
taylor's
hankinson was arraigned in a hearing via
telephone and was ordered not to have
any firearms
he's currently out on a 15 thousand
dollar bond a judge has
also ordered the recordings of the
briana taylor grand jury proceedings to
be made public that ruling came after
one of the grand jurors filed a motion
asking as such protesters took to the
streets after the announcement of the
grand jury's indictment
an attorney for one of the jurors said
they want the proceedings released
so that truth may prevail the attorney
cited great public interest and
arguments for why the jurors
should be allowed to speak freely here
are some of the jurors arguments the
citizens of this commonwealth have
demonstrated their lack of faith in the
process
and proceedings in this matter and the
justice system itself
using the grand jurors as a shield to
deflect accountability
and responsibility for these decisions
only sows more seeds of doubt
in the process while leaving a cold
chill down the spines of future
grand jurors the juror specifically
cited the kentucky
attorney general's own words at a press
conference following the indictment of
the one officer
here is what the ag said at the time
grand jury proceedings are are secret
and so i'm not going to get into the
specifics
of of details about that
proceeding what i will say is that we
presented all of the information
and they ultimately made a determination
about
whether to charge in this instance they
decided to indict
detective hankinson well what my role as
the special prosecutor in this case
was to provide the information and facts
to the grand jury
detective cosgrove and sergeant
mattingly
were justified in returning fire because
they were fired upon
a.g cameron responded to the judge's
order to release the grand jury
recordings this way
we stand by our belief that such a
release could compromise the ongoing
federal investigation
and could have unintended consequences
such as poisoning the jury pool
despite these concerns we will comply
with the judge's
recording or decision rather to release
the recording so brian does the ag have
a valid point here can he turn around
and say well there's other
investigations this might jeopardize
what about the investigation you just
completed
he he does have a point right you don't
want to
taint any future jury pulls however this
case has been going on for over a
hundred days
any jury pool that might have been
tainted surprise surprise it already is
people have decided
what the facts are already however his
words as to how he describes a grand
jury process
raises more than a few eyebrows and
suggests that he did not do this
properly
okay so terry the grand juror who filed
this paperwork in court to basically get
these things out in the public
seems a little bit more worried about
transparency
than he or she seems to be suggesting a
specific cover-up is that a proper way
to read this
i would read it that way because not
only is this juror
talking about transparency or looking
for it but so
is the community so when you have as
brian said a case that takes so long and
when you have charges that don't even
relate
to brianna taylor the one person who was
killed people want to know what exactly
was presented to that
grand jury they need to have
transparency because the specifics of
this case
are so bizarre so brian the ag is
turning around saying okay i will comply
i will comply what would happen if he
didn't contempt
it would be a legal battle this isn't
complying like oh i'm choosing to do
this
this is complying like your mother told
you it's time to go to bed and you have
to do it like
he can't do anything else he can't sit
up and say well i still want to read my
comic books i mean
you know look terry he's he's got to
release this the bottom line
is we will have a lot more answers
starting tomorrow about this process
yes that's true and you know what aaron
most of the time the grand jury
proceedings
are not released but here you have the
fact that they have to be and so you
know we're going to see what happened
and we're going to see
exactly what was presented exactly terry
austin brian buckmeyer thanks for the
analysis
thank you for joining us here on law and
prime daily where we discuss justice in
america
we'll see you next time
i'm dan abrams and this is the lawn
crime network
the only 24 7 network with expert legal
analysis
and gavel to gavel live trial coverage
watch the law on crime network today
[Music]
you